the central Philippine province of Albay
in a state of disaster on Friday
authorities went from Village to Village
at the foot of the Mayon Volcano to move
residents to temporary shelters away
from the threat of an eruption
scientists say they've observed an
increase in activity that could lead to
a dangerous explosion
possible scenarios first is the 2014
scenario wherein there were only rock
falls or it could be like 2018 when
there was a major eruption
despite the warning areas around the
volcano aren't a no man's land yet Mayon
Volcano That Mountain behind me that's
shrouded in clouds is one of the most
active volcanoes in the Philippines it
threatens to erupt every few years now
this area is within its six kilometer
radius declared as a permanent danger
zone but thousands of people live here
some families have taken a day to weigh
up their options the delatorices are
getting ready to leave after the
government ordered evacuations
life in the evacuation Center isn't easy
we sleep on the ground there are cash
stipends but we don't get them right
away
Eden alemania says she's worried about
their crops in livestock but for the
sake of her children she's decided to go
we here in field of volcano rumbling
then last night the summit was glowing
my own volcano is a part of their lives
but how can anyone get used to it they
ask when the choice is solving between
life and death
Barney below Al Jazeera I'll buy the
Philippines